I spend a large portion of my career
working on JavaScript on the desktop
either for tooling or for frameworks
that build it and one of the things that
might be most known for at least in
France is this little stunt I built a
couple of weeks ago where put all of
Windows 95 into an application which is
specifically electron turns out you can
run a virtual machine and JavaScript
fairly efficiently if you care about the
resources right so this is a full
virtual machine and works well and one
of the things I learned fairly early on
is that JavaScript on the desktop is a
little bit like CGI and what I mean by
that is that whenever JavaScript on the
desktop is noticed by people it tends to
upset the horns right the tends to upset
hacker news reddit is angry everyone is
sort of angry and the thing the video is
not compared with CGI is because I don't
think many people realize how much
JavaScript actually is running on the
desktop machines in various applications
so I have just three examples for you
real quick
the first one being a battlefield one
the user interface is built in react and
typescript and MA packs there's about a
thousand components that render
ammunition the weapons you know the
whole user interface and nobody's ever
complained about javascript in
battlefield one simply because they
don't really realize right it's just not
all that present but it turns out that
user interfaces and games build with
JavaScript aren't all that unique and we
heard earlier today about Minecraft the
second example in this case just note
yes is the NVIDIA GeForce experience is
a tool that comes pre-installed on most
Windows computers today at least the
ones that come with an NVIDIA GPU and
the GeForce experience comes with nodejs
I don't actually know what they used to
build the user interface that nodejs is
used for game streaming and background
task orchestration and all kinds of
things and if you happen to have a
Windows computer you can probably just
open up the folder where the GeForce
experience lives and you will find a
node modules folder that's sort of like
proofs that whole thing out and then
lastly on the other side of the spectrum
we have the Creative Suite
by Adobe Photoshop Premiere illustrator
all those tools actually ship with a
full version of Chrome and nodejs for
something called the common extension
platform plugins in Adobe's platform are
built with no J's in Chrome for pretty
much the same reason we have electron
today
and that reason is that if you combine
Chrome with no GS you have a really good
tool for building cross-platform
applications right it's really effective
you know about all the popular apps and
we heard about a few slackers obviously
one of them but this there's a lot of
applications that you might not know
about my personal favorite is the Visual
Studio installer the tool that installs
the big Visual Studio is an electron app
which always gives me a lot of joy as
someone who used to work at Microsoft
and whenever whenever electron has come
up as someone who come in Taine's
electron whenever I go anywhere and I
talk about electron the project the
first thing that comes up is performance
right people always want to talk about
performance it's one thing that worried
about an performance means different
things to different people which i think
is fair the most common thing I hear
about is memory right people are saying
electron uses too much memory how can it
use less memory the thing I personally
worry about is battery life how can we
make sure that electron applications are
just a little bit more lightweight do
less work and then from any developers
it's actually something entirely
different its speed how quickly can I
get a certain task done right visual
studio code for instance spend an insane
amount of resources on making sure that
visual studio code launches in less than
I think 20 milliseconds it's very very
quick if you consider the amount of
processes that are being spun up and
what I'm going to talk about real quick
are four things that I look for when I
think about performance on the desktop
just for and my theory is that
JavaScript on the desktop wherever you
find it more than others and games or in
CLI tools or in package managers or even
an electron apps those four things are
probably not being done that's my theory
JavaScript could be a lot faster if we
write it better so I'm just gonna go
over those four things the first one I'm
gonna start with modules that's the
thing that worries me the most
so what you see up there is code that
many of us would write we're gonna try
to check whether or not the DOJ's home
page is reachable and this is a typical
task we're on a server you would
probably just go to NPM find this is
reachable module go ahead and run this
code this it doesn't look like there's
anything wrong with this code but
if you consider how much work is being
done in the require statement there's so
much in this function if you ever check
out the module loader nodejs I mean it's
open source you can just look at it but
it's a pretty big file that does a lot
of work we've heard this today before
let's look at what this function
actually does before you even run a
single line of code so we run this
script in node and the first thing is we
do is we go to is reachable and we look
at the index of j/s and that in extra J
is also has a bunch of required
statements at the very top right one of
them being port numbers and then you
look at port numbers important numbers
itself also has require Simmons at the
very top and two of them adjacent files
ninety-four thousand lines of Jason that
all being parsed before you even run a
single line of code it's reachable it's
a good example because that particular
issue has been fixed that's been fixed
in multiple ways but this happens to so
many people they import an
innocent-looking module and all of a
sudden their applications are extremely
slow and they just don't know why and
one of the reasons they don't know why
is because those modules do a lot of
work before we even got to run any
functions right so what can we do right
this is our code the first thing we can
do is we can just go and require the
whole thing later right it's a method
just do it later just do it at a time we
actually need it in this case we are not
doing any of this annoying work until
the actual method is being called which
already allows the rest of the
application to continue executing delays
the whole work the thing that you should
probably actually do though my opinion
is not use a module at all right it's
the most common answer especially if
you're shipping your own version of
nodejs which is the case an electron is
the case and many of the examples that
are talked about today you know exactly
what kind of methods are available and
chances are that most people use is
reachable never worried about port
numbers that 94 thousand lines of port
numbers was just a list of which port is
associated with which service most
people didn't need that and it's
reachable by the way no longer requires
port numbers to begin with
so once you've realized that once you've
like started thinking about how much
work require actually is you can go in
and go a little
further right so no js' has v8 and v8 is
a JavaScript engine and what this
javascript engine does is it uses
just-in-time compilation what that means
is every single time you run a little
JavaScript it goes ahead and allows us
your code and turns it into something
your machine can actually execute that
is an expensive operation that takes a
decent amount of time and in chrome if
you keep visiting the same website today
eventually chrome will this stop doing
that I will just be like I compile this
before let me just go and grab it real
quick I don't need to recompile it if
you're running JavaScript on the desktop
and you probably are if you're using NPM
yarn any of those things you can do the
same thing right there what you see
right here is the entry script for a
yarn a little cut-down
and the very first thing they do is they
load something the v8 compiled cache
which is a little module that basically
replaces require and allows you to at
the second time you load any script to
go back to the already compiled blob so
you never pre-compile things twice in
the case of yarn that cut time Don from
about 180 milliseconds 220 and that
module is now also in bobble core it
made babble court dramatically faster
and if we wanted to use it that's what
we would do we would just require the
module don't really have to do anything
else keep doing the same work that we've
done before but you know just make
things a little easier all around on the
code so long story short whenever you
run npm install you might be making
application a lot slower just think
about how are you spending resources at
the beginning and then the second big
thing is painting I don't think enough
JavaScript developers actually think
about the paint operation like what is
going on every single time we need to
take web stuff and turn that into pixels
and as an example I hope dr. J's will
forgive me but as an example is look at
the DOJ's homepage right just as an
example and it's a great page it's
beautiful it just would make a terrible
application I'm going to show you why so
what you see here on the screen there we
go
what you see on the green and the screen
every single time something flashes in
green that's a paint
that's an expensive operation we're
repainting the screen and I want you to
look at that little red number in the
upper right that is my CPU of a
20:18 MacBook Pro picking up to 50%
every now and then and it's speaking up
there even if you scroll down because
the way the animation is under the very
top the whole page needs to be repainted
every couple of seconds sorry multiple
times a second and just keeping this
page open will keep my CPU busy at 30%
just not doing anything with it just
leaving it there and my theory is that
those developer tools are really really
good and if people look at them they
will be able to build tools and websites
that are a lot lighter in resources
right this is part of chrome dev tools
it's pretty amazing stuff you can use it
too there's a lot of documentation about
it but my theory and I'm not sure if I'm
right but my theory is that not enough
that developers actually look at this
stuff right because as web developers we
weren't really taught to worry about
battery impact that's something most
people don't think about I don't know
about you but the people of my team
definitely don't know what kind of
battery impacted PR has I they they just
don't know and these tools can help you
do that now the third piece yeah there
we go
the third piece is naturally speaking
not all code is equal in native
development electron furnace is most
built with C++ and in native development
it's fairly easy for us to benchmark
code it's not all that much harder in
JavaScript I just feel like as a
community all of us including me have
less of a practice of doing it all the
time
and we probably should be doing a lot
more so in this example I just want to
get all the divs that have a certain
class name pretty common operation and
in the past we were using jQuery right
in the early days and then queryselector
came along and we stopped using jQuery
and used the query selector instead in
this example obviously this is going to
be bad right that's why I'm showing it
as an example but it's not unique I just
wanted to like make up a number in your
mind how many percent query selector is
lower than get elements by class name
just make up a number it's 99 percent
it's a lot like by the time I've done
almost 30 million get elements by class
name I haven't even run all four hundred
thousand query select operations and
this is just one
sample right this is just one chances
are that if I look at your code we can
be just benchmark a little bit of it we
can find a lot of stuff that in the
latest version of Chrome is way slower
than a less cool old JavaScript method
right so I guess the the lesson here is
check your assumptions just because it's
new doesn't mean it's fast in most cases
actually means it's pretty slow which is
sad but that's just the way it is and if
I can just throw in a little like
nitpick don't make promises out of stuff
that don't need it to be promises
promises are great I love them but
overhead cut it out and now since we're
already thinking about code and we can
optimize code a little I don't think I
have people realize that no js' is
perfectly capable of running native code
and by extension also electron is
perfectly capable of running native code
and whenever I encounter any kind of
problems that can't be solved with
normal JavaScript I can very easily just
go to C or C++ and obviously the main
reason I usually do that an electron
landis because I need to make some kind
of sis call that I can't be making in
front of GS right like some dumb Winn
API stuff and I very rarely actually
have instances where I can't write
JavaScript that is good enough to be
performant but every now and then there
are cases and it's like for instance a
lot of the calling your video calls a
lot of the calling are actually
happening in native code because that's
just a more performant way to do it
javascript does have limits but electron
are using nucleus doesn't mean you
subscribe to those limits it's perfectly
fine to build 98% of your cross-platform
application in JavaScript and then do
the last 2% in C++ but there's still a
lot better than building the whole thing
in C++ right because it's not like a
like C++ I'm terrible at it
it's a foot gun you will definitely
shoot yourself in the foot and you lose
some memory left and right with what
this come from
but it's doable right and because we're
live in 2018 we also not limited to C++
I personally I don't know how this
became clear but I hate C++ the worst
but we have rust now and if you use
tools like parcel you can literally just
import a rust file and we'll figure it
out there's nothing you need to do
frankly you need to have the rust tools
installed but you can literally just
import the rust method which by the way
looks like this
I wrote here it's not very smart but
rust looks pretty friendly it is pretty
friendly and the idea is that if you
have an operation you need to call many
many many times and it takes a long time
and because I don't know maybe you
didn't some complex math just do it
natively it's gonna be good enough okay
and then lastly and that's the fourth
point and how how useful that point is
really depends on the application right
it doesn't make a lot of sense for
Battlefield it doesn't make a lot of
sense for let's say any CLI scripts but
it certainly makes a lot of sense for
the applications like the NVIDIA GeForce
experience or many electron applications
and that is that if you build a website
you sort of live in this like paternal
state of the browser the browser is
taking care of your resources and it's a
little bit like money if you're a
website the browser gives you just a
little allowance and it's sort of like
figured out that it's not giving you
more now understand you're supposed to
have but if you're a desktop application
you have free rein you can pick all CPU
cores if you want to you can keep the
whole computer from shutting down right
there's absolutely this is actually PR
that Leonard earlier today an electron
someone figured out how to prevent
Windows shutdowns from electron so
that's going to be a feature soon I
guess
and that stuff there websites don't get
but my point here is that if you're a
desktop application you're writing
JavaScript for discipline respect the
fact that you might not be the favorite
child on the computer right now right if
the application is minimized
maybe stop pulling every couple of
seconds if you have some going to
service you need to subscribe to maybe
just pass Network requests until the
application comes back up into view and
interestingly enough the example I have
here document dot hidden if you're
running on a Mac document that hidden
will be true if the application is up
but like completely covered by something
else I can find a window which is super
useful right you can stop animations
stop playing videos stop doing all kinds
of all kinds of stuff that is expensive
you just saw the painting ad if for
instance extremely expensive if you're
using slack nothing will kill your
battery life quicker than uploading a 50
megabyte if to your colleagues follow
them to see so that can be extremely
effective so I'm just going to summarize
my four points real quick the first one
is think about modules think about
modules and there have been so many
jokes about no modules folders that are
infinitely deep but I don't think they
really have to be this is not a thing
that we as traffic developers can figure
out and I think the answer usually is to
just use less of them just be a little
bit more mindful right the next time you
import requests in something that is not
a server application consider that
request is always a megabyte of
JavaScript which is many lines probably
more lines than you have in your
application or I have in my application
it's a lot if you're just calling
requests get maybe just use you know
fetch or something else
and the second point was just use the
developer tools figure out half in your
painting figure out what your layout
actually demands and the third point
interestingly enough the third point was
to maybe not use JavaScript but if you
do use JavaScript benchmark it a little
check your assumptions and the fourth
point was to respect the operating
system the operating system wants to
help you gives you all kinds of events
on when to like shutdown and when to use
a little bit less work and we JavaScript
developers should also do a little less
work whenever we're not really needed to
do 60 frames a second of Jif rendering
at the given moment if you ever have any
trouble building a performant an
external application and you feel like
it's definitely impossible to do so
please just find me on Twitter because
there surely are some use cases they
shouldn't build an electron but
generally speaking you can make Elektra
Maps perform and it's definitely doable
so please just find me on Twitter if you
feel like you're having a hard time
thank you very much
[Applause]